shoulders
[Music]
this is the initial hazardous materials
yeah there you go yeah
five for mind you so 5 000 people
evacuated it's they're not they're not
really talking about it pat they're
saying that a guy let his dog out to get
water five minutes later dog dropped
dead miles and miles away from the look
look at that tell me what does that look
like Pat that's like True by the way
that's from a plane airplane yeah so
mind you thousands of fish fish are
dying and this just this just goes to
show you bro uh this is when you hire
just for diversity because you know he's
the head of Transportation how many
times can this guy drop the ball the
only reason got that job and I'm being
straight up is because he's a gay man
there's no zero Patrick zero
qualifications Rob go on his Wikipedia
what is what does Pete bootage you know
about Transportation mind you this is
the same guy drives a car that that 100
same guy during the supply chain crisis
guess what he did two month maternity
leave with his husband paternity leave
have a little respect whatever it was
for two months while we were going with
that for 200 once he was gone how many
mistakes like can happen and keep going
both this is a disaster you know what he
was yesterday he didn't make one mention
of what's happening this is this is
really really bad guess what he was
talking about diversity in the workforce
he was saying that like when yeah White
Construction there's too many white
construction workers bro people this is
a cancerous thing I saw vehicles that
had the front of their bumpers Adam the
stuff is like melting pieces of the
plastic on the car he was talking about
how racism he's on the America's racist
tour that's what he's doing that's what
America is is worried about is that and
he's the main guy same thing with Kamala
when you just hire because it's either
race or the sexual their choice that's
what you get and it's ridiculous and by
the way what happened so this is this is
are you following the story or no oh
this is the first time yeah but I want
to I want to hear more yeah so so this
is Houston then I'm sorry this is a
Palestine Ohio the next day it's South
Carolina if you have that one uh uh this
is this is South Carolina or this is
okay let's let's see this one
can do you have a clip of it or what is
it shown
is it showing anything or no just that
train right there you would say it
derailed I see it yeah what are the odds
Pat of three separate trains yeah all
derailing all dropping toxic like really
really really bad chemicals all in that
and that that spam and by the way do you
know do you know the county of Palestine
Ohio is 70 Republicans they voted 70
Trump in 2020. just so you know that
I'll be serious with you yeah Palestine
Ohio
is a very uh uh big Republican town yeah
so I I and by the way I'm not I'm not
going to that so that could be just a
purely coincidence on that taking place
but what what are what are people saying
with the is there is there a common
threat amongst the three uh uh you know
Ohio South Carolina and Houston or no no
and and from from what I did from the
research that I did a lot some you know
some people are are saying like maybe
it's like a Cyber attack where they're
coming like the communication is wrong
that that thing is going on the wrong
track and falling off and then like I
said earlier Pat it's like almost like a
coincidence when people are like
something about Epstein is coming out
and mind you did you know this Pat
what's coming out about the Epstein
situation Rob is they're going to
release all his business partners all
the suspected uh Predators all his
victims all that P All That is supposed
to come out tomorrow and a lot of a lot
of people are saying that this is just
like the UFO situation because you know
that Pat that's a fact defense secretary
Lloyd Austin said and I quote three
objects taken down this weekend are
totally different from the Chinese Bible
so what is it you can't tell us what
what are these F-16 shooting down if
they're even shooting down anything some
people are saying it's a distraction all
this is a big distraction so you don't
know tomorrow tomorrow's a really really
big day I want to see if it still
happens if the Epstein list is going to
come out well let me ask you this though
I mean if if the people behind it
um have so much power that they are able
to derail trains and
I have UFOs flying around the United
States why wouldn't they have the power
to not to release those documents or to
or to destroy them I mean So based on
your research Vincent well basically yes
no based on my researchers it's going to
come out but if you have people
distracted mind you people walked in you
were one of them he was one of them you
guys had no idea that there was
something a controlled substance spewing
into uh on our on American soil that's
gonna definitely cause cancer it's
killing animals it's killing fish nobody
really knows about it so the more they
have you thinking about UFOs people know
more about the spot there's UFOs down
people think nobody knows about the
Epstein thing did you guys even know
that that's coming out tomorrow did you
have anything oh absolutely so what I'm
saying is that's a great my point is put
as much distraction as you can out there
because tomorrow when this comes out
nobody's gonna care just like when the
JFK files are coming out people are like
okay we know just like the Twitter files
people get it they're they're on they're
in Congress right now trying to you know
hold these people accountable that were
fired from Twitter but you know what
people's attention in Spanish like it'll
go away is this information going to be
unreducted because I'd be quite
surprised and Rob can you find out if if
the Epstein I I think it's just a list
man I think it's gonna be a list of
everybody that was a victim everybody he
had business dealings with everybody
that was on this island the whole list
is supposed to come out tomorrow but how
do we know everybody who should be on
the list is you know I mean I live in DC
I don't believe anything I don't believe
it you know if I may yes I just Googled
some information by the way I don't
think there's
any correlation between train
derailments and Jeffrey Epstein but if
you want to go down that path I want you
to research it what I did do research is
uh you know I used to take the train to
work from Miami to Boca for years
years it was a grind this is part of the
reason I'm a car and once a week someone
was got hit by a trade like I'm an hour
late to work today I thought I'd get
there early no it was a train issue it's
a train issue so as I'm hearing more
about these train issues I'm like well
let's see how common these things are do
your do your research Beyond this yeah
yeah uh it says how many trained
railments are in the U.S each year it
says while fatalities from train
derailments are rare
derailments themselves are actually
quite common since 1990 the first year
that they began tracking train
derailments and injuries on a yearly
basis up to 2021. uh there have been 54
000 accidents in which a Train derailed
that's an average of 1700 train
derailments per year so it seems to be
freaking common now obviously I'm going
to assume that some of them are minor of
course some of them are major they seem
to be major yeah uh but I would you I
want you to to go deeper on this okay
but here's my here's my thing Google how
many times in one month less than a
month three trains dropping hundreds of
thousands no no don't that's what I'm
saying that is re this is not uh
we're in agreement that some weird [__]
is happening derailment that you're
talking about could be like it hit
another train no doubt but but here my
thing is this I can have an opinion and
my opinion is this past month from Bible
mind you NORAD I don't know what the
hell norad's what's going on they have
no idea that this spy balloon didn't
they didn't track it till it came over
Canada and hit us but guess what if it's
TR if it's a Santa Claus tracker they're
like hey it's coming over a lot they
know where the Santa Claus tracker is
they don't know what the the goddamn
Chinese spy balloons are and I'm shocked
that we can even call it a Chinese spy
balloon because it's racist to even say
that this thing is coming from over no I
mean it's it's funny but it's not funny
I think I think it's a serious thing
hundreds the thing is still burning that
five thousand uh persons sitting uh is
evacuated and those people are making
videos and they're complaining bro
because they're making like it's not a
big deal why isn't the government so
Vinnie tie it all together for me what's
happening I'm tying it all together and
that when you have uh the Secretary of
Transportation on a tour telling people
about how there's lack of diversity why
isn't he talking the first thing he
should be talking about is this problem
this is a dude this isn't just okay they
spilled some you know gas and it's gonna
disappear that's it's burning and these
people are getting affected it's
cancerous [__] I think your point is
Pete bootages has some explaining to do
100 but he'll but they'll never hold him
accountable bro he he has no business
being the head of Transportation she has
no why is she even speaking the White
House Press for secretary Kamala Harris
they're horrible at their job but nobody
holds them accountable you're not good
at your job if if people did you worked
at McDonald's and he did that many
mistakes he would have been gone on the
on the second fry [__] up that question
let me ask a question so out of all the
things out of by the way Pete putitch is
not qualified for this at all I mean you
you know he's not qualified for this job
that deal was made that Tuesday or
whatever the day was when himself
Elizabeth Warren Bernie everybody
dropped out and they said uh Joe Biden
is going to be the candidate and that
the day the way that deal was broken
okay I'll step down if you give me XYZ
job hey since you like driving Teslas
you're the transportation guy you know
Kamala you're gonna be this and you're
gonna do this and you're gonna I don't
even know if he drives a Tesla he may
drive a Prius for I know he may drive a
Ford Focus but all I'm saying is he got
a job yeah for the hell of it so let's
set let's set aside Pete bootage here uh
uh with what he's doing he's going to be
one of their Superstars just so you know
he's a superstar for the left yeah
um
sometimes when things like this happen
you have to also know like uh you're
distracting the audience which is the
American people from a real issue that
is going on if we go and we think about
the last 30 days or the last two weeks
what's really been the biggest story
that could hit that really could you
know some [__] could go down all right
for example
um North stream pipeline I'm happy to
pick that up you look at North stream
pipeline you know the story that was
written by the two-time Pulitzer uh
prize uh uh winner uh uh Hirsch what's
his first name Seymour her she wrote to
somebody he's had some stories that have
worked against him whatever we're not
sitting here you know we have to give
that as well he's got a couple stories
that he did that actually didn't know
but he made some claims years ago that
was actually right and he's known for
being the guy that does great
investigative journalism which is what
their job is supposed to be and the
whole story is about what the fact that
U.S was behind North stream pipeline why
would Russia do this to themselves when
they own 50.1 percent of it it's like me
owning a business for 50.1 percent of
business and I blow it up myself and I
need the money and I'm in the middle of
a war with a country called Ukraine that
I used to be my land and I need as much
Resource as possible to fund this war
and yeah let me go blow up my own North
stream pipeline No One Believes that's
possible we know that lady that came out
and texted and says done you know
finished yeah yeah finished and then we
also know when Joe Biden do you have the
clip of what Joe Biden said about the
north stream pipeline when he gave the
answer and the ladies like well how do
you know that how are you so certain do
you remember his answers yes just trust
just trust me I know you know so no
one's touching this so why why is this
so important why is the so if you can
play this clip give me context because
you're saying because what that guy's
saying is that Navy Seals went in there
underwater frogmen and blew up we blew
up that that pipe yeah that's what he
was saying so we're gonna be honest with
you I'll read the article so please I'll
read the article so you know Pulitzer
Prize winning Seymour harsh uh has
alleged uh has alleged U.S Navy divers
if you have the New York Post story if
you don't have it I'll text it to you
right now Robin you can pull it up but
I'm going to read it myself while we're
going through this so uh the story that
he is
Navy divers yeah so so you as a U.S Navy
divers laid bombs that destroyed the
north stream to natural gas pipeline
under the Baltic Sea last September
drawn a denial from Pentagon Wednesday
Hirsch who scoop journalism type of
words from five decades ago for exposing
the Malay Massacre of Vietnamese
civilians by U.S troops in 1968 cited an
unnamed Source in reporting on substack
that Americans planted remotely
triggered explosive that wrecked three
of our four pipeline three of the four
pipelines built to carry natural gas
from Russia to Europe Hirsch 85 want to
claim that the Navy conducted an
operation undercover of a NATO uh
Maritime exercise called ball tops 22. I
don't know if you have the story ball
tops 22 in a short statement Pentagon
spokesman Marine Corps Lieutenant
Colonel Garen Garn told the post the
United States was not involved in the
Nordstrom explosion reiterating the
defense Department's response to the
same question in October Swedish
officials suspected the ball blast were
the result of gross sabotage and some
Western officials
were quick to blame the attacks on
Moscow do you realize how dumb if you
actually believe yeah for somebody like
say Elon Musk he himself brought down
Tesla and Twitter because he just kind
of felt like yeah right and he when he
owned 51 percent of it if he did okay
and it blocked his cat gas supplies to
Europe in response to sanctions over
last year's Invasion to Ukraine these
are deliberate actions not an accident
Danish Prime Minister met Fredrickson
said at the time the situation is as
serious it gets anyways so these are the
claims that he's making okay and then
Biden gets up and he's asked the
question if he can find this clip if he
can find this clip because all of this
is coming down to the ICBM that just U.S
accidentally practiced just three days
ago launching and Us's government
pentagon is telling everybody to get out
of Russia at a time like this so do you
have the clip of what he says is this
the one okay uh president from Tucker's
show where I think okay that's it let's
hear it so this is her and him press
both of them play both of them yeah
so this is what she says at the state
department the number two of the state
department watch and Joe Biden
threatened to blow up the nordstream
pipeline watch
I want to be clear with you today if
Russia invades Ukraine one way or
another nordstream 2 will not move
forward if Russia invades that means
tanks or troops crossing the uh the
border of Ukraine again then there will
be uh we there will be no longer on
North stream too if we we will bring an
end to it
how will you do that
exactly since the project and control of
the project is within Germany's controls
we will uh I promise you we'll be able
to do it what does that even so then the
pipe yeah what do you mean I promise
yeah we will be able to do that you sent
two frog men in there what interest what
interest does Russia have to do that
right think about the interest of Russia
okay what interest do they have to do
that so all right so you I asked the
question from you earlier is this a
distraction these trains are these
balloons of distractions like hey look
over here oh [__] we're dealing with
something really big here here's a story
for you nothing to see here U.S test
launches us test launches ICBM into
Pacific as part of nuclear deterrence
Mission okay this is U.S news and World
Report times the U.S Air Force test
launched an unarmed intercontinental
ballistic missile the Minuteman the
third into the Pacific Ocean claiming
the launch was a routine a name that
reassuring allies of course it's just a
routine of course the timing is a little
crazy but don't worry people it's just
routine yeah the Air Force Global strike
command asserted the test was intended
to demonstrate that the United States
nuclear and deterrent is safe secure and
reliable and effective to deter 21st
century threats the English language
Global times China state-run newspaper
has suggested China's developing its
nuclear Arsenal facet in the U.S which
possesses a Cold War era stockpile that
is aging and North Korea was also
paraded in its large ever collection of
nuclear missiles and Russia has deployed
a warship with hypersonic nuclear
warheads into InterContinental Waters
near the U.S these developments have
alarmed European nations which are
hesitant to supply potent weapons to
Ukraine obviously you know how you go to
like an air show and they're just kind
of entertaining you this is all they're
doing guys folks if you're listening to
this it's just simply a form of
entertainment for for the American
people and what a great timing right
imagine did anybody know that we're
testing like because I'm module I worked
at a nuclear missile base in Mount Storm
Air Force Base Montana where this
Chinese spy balloon was just hovering
and not collecting data it was just it
was just flying around and it's somehow
some way and then I'll pause you and
I'll turn it over to you guys and I'll
you know hey if you can go to this NPR
story while all this stuff is going on
while all this stuff yeah NPR is not Fox
News it's not this is not pry bar this
is not CNN this is NPR NPR is left
leaning government-funded media so you
have to realize who NPR is okay the US
is urging Americans to leave Russia
immediately due to security risks the
U.S embassy in Moscow is urging
Americans to leave Russia immediately
due to security risk amid the war in
Ukraine the U.S embassy in Moscow warned
the unpredictable consequences of the
war in Ukraine and said that the U.S
Russian citizen has particular risk
being forcibly conscripted into Russia's
armed forces the embassy also cautioned
that Americans in general face potential
harassment or wrongful detention by
Russian Security Services the Kremlin
Shrugged off calls of Americans to leave
the country as not new next week will
mark one year since Russia invaded
Ukraine on February 22 before 2022 so
again maybe these you know trains maybe
these you know balloons you know it's
very easy to to distract kids with
balloons it's I got three balloons at
the top that's all Brooklyn sees in the
house she loves them the same way you
can distract kids with balloons is the
same way you distract adults with
balloons that could be the case again I
am purely speculating I don't have an
Insider person telling me anything I'm
purely speculating but Pat have you
when's the last time when's the last
time this much besides 911 all the crazy
stuff that we went through when's the
last time you heard about three trains
like this yeah uh uh UFOs because that's
what the defense secretary Lloyd Lawson
said three identified unidentified
flying objects a Chinese spy balloon
that's just coming over they're shooting
down these things that they won't give
us any explanation of what they are
they're not telling us about this until
Americans were recording it and going yo
what what is that then they have to
explain themselves but we have the
highest defense budget in the world no I
was in the United States Air Force I can
tell you nobody fly nothing is in the
air unless we know that it's in there
but all of a sudden we're letting them
come in the UFOs are happening three
trains are dumping all this stuff the
stuff it's just so much is going on I do
want to know what people like what do
you think what do you think there's
anything that they're trying to distract
Us in or you just think it's just ah
this is just American [__] happens and
it's just happening for regarding the
just every I'm just saying everything
this is a crazy time as much and with
the north stream Pipeline and everything
that's happening I'll address the the
Chinese weather balloon stuff right
there I've watched a lot lot of content
on it and I think
the pervasive view is that we have a lot
more questions and answers so I think
that we are there's going to be the
Senate Judiciary hearings on whatever's
going to come up the accountability like
we're going to find out what the hell's
going on here uh I don't think this is
going to lead to any sort of hot war
with China I think we can pump the
brakes on that I think there's no uh
debate that China is our uh I'm not I
don't want to use the word enemy
adversary adversary sure so there's
certainly an adversary role but I do
want to focus on the Nordstrom too
because there was two schools of thought
was it Putin why would Putin do this
that you know Putin with his amazing
sense of humor did make a joke about six
months ago when winter was starting yeah
and it was essentially he was telling a
story about a a German boy speaking to
his father about you know why why does
the why do the Russians hate us oh they
don't want us to be warm winter it this
you know this it wasn't a very funny
joke essentially he was basically saying
you know why why do why are we so cold
here in Germany you know because the
world wants us to the world wants the
Russians to suffer it he's like well are
we Russians because we're suffering is
essentially what the premise was so from
from the Putin state of uh state of mind
he's like if we do this we're going to
make
Europe pay by the way Europe has
wholeheartedly embraced the war in
Ukraine every single EU nation is
wholeheartedly on team Ukraine of course
no debate there the entire EU you'll
speak about this probably much more
eloquently than I what I would say is
this
from a non-political standpoint if the
U.S is at war with Russia again
non-politically
wouldn't it kind of make sense to blow
up the [__] Nordstrom to to limit
their ability to pump out oil and and
drive Revenue so whether you like Biden
hate Biden think he's an old senile man
whether he literally it was a gaff and
let one go If This Were conventional
Warfare and we blew up our enemies
pipeline we would all secretly being
like hey good job over here great job
America yeah but in this political
climate we're like what an idiot why
would he uh yeah so I don't necessarily
if we did do it and we sent what do you
call them Frogman Frogman okay whatever
that is yeah putting their uh you know
yeah I would say all right well I guess
we're pretty calculated here in the
military uh but you're from a former
USSR czechoslovak well not exactly
former the Empire
Eastern block correct yes so I'm not I'm
not wrong here what's your take on
what's going on by the way just so we're
clear here do you know the death toll if
you know it just let the audience guess
do you know the death toll of the
current amount of Russians and
ukrainians that have died in the last
year both come on total combined do you
have any idea I have no idea take a wild
guess 5000 500 000 do you know how many
that is in a year to die 500. is that my
right no but just keep in mind in the
entire uh U.S Ward Vietnam I think we
had 50 000 casualties okay six years
whatever friends do you know the number
I have no I just I just ran I thought it
was something you wrote how much 200 000
each I thought two hundred thousand each
you Russians have lost 200
000 soldiers and ukrainians almost a
hundred thousand I'm kind of close
according to Norwegian TV and January
22nd General Eric Christopherson
obviously we have big fans of Norway
here we trust their uh research Kai yeah
uh Norwegian Norway's defense says
estimates that over a hundred and eighty
thousand have been killed in Ukraine and
a hundred thousand Ukraine Russians have
been killed in Ukraine I think something
that we're forgetting about because we
were all in the raw raw sister you know
behind Ukraine all right there's a war
this is a year ago support Ukraine what
is actually happening is there a
staggering amount of deaths and just
overall just destruction going on there
there's a full-on war there's a war in
America we're like hey support Ukraine
donate I work an extra dollars people
are [__] dying oh yeah you don't
think that there's a hundred thousand
two hundred thousand Russian moms that
are crying
what a great point I don't know that
much that's nuts
well I suddenly don't think that the
Europeans are acting as though Russia is
a serious threat to the peace and
stability in Europe uh the United States
has been uh heroic in in the amount of
uh Hardware that the United States has
been providing to
um to Ukraine not to mention budgetary
support but it shows you just how weak
the European countries are they've been
relying on the United States for support
for defense since the establishment of
NATO in the 1940s they constantly
refused to meet the meet their targets
in terms of spending on defense and they
have been they've been very cheap when
it comes to supporting uh the ukrainians
they've been relying on the United
States uh the the Brits uh have done a
fair bit uh the French are dragging
their feet uh Germans even more so as
far as the Spanish and the Portuguese
are concerned I I don't even know if
they are aware there's a war going on so
so I I would love to see the Europeans
actually stepping up and if they feel
that Russia is really an existential
threat to Europe that they should do
their bit rather than constantly rely on
the United States
clearly it's the countries that Finland
Poland yeah that are surrounding the
polls understand what Russians can do
when they take over your country they've
seen it and and the same with uh with
the Baltic versus the Portuguese and the
Spanish they're just like Siesta time
and Pat this this goes to me like with
all this stuff and I'm not I'm not
trying to make it political but I mean
we're talking politics with everything
that's going wrong here as we're seeing
it the wars that we're getting involved
with China being able to literally
literally from covid to what they're
doing now do whatever they want and get
away with it because to me personally
the administration the President Biden
weak as hell I would much rather meet
persons in my opinion is my thought I
would much rather go back to two years
ago when the only thing hurting in this
country was people's feelings nothing
country itself I'm being real two years
ago people were like hey he said
something mean none of this [__] would
have been happening during Trump I put I
put my money around my mouth you'd think
a a balloon spying would just be flying
over and all this [__] would be
happening with China it's the same guy
that tried to hold China accountable and
just because he was like oh this is a
China virus you can't it's racism
China's doing whatever the hell they
want we owe them all this freaking money
heroin I saw a documentary where a
homeless guy very well spoken and yeah
he was homeless but whatever he's like
look what Chinese do he was heroin we
don't heroin's gone he goes fentanyl is
the number one thing coming here from
China they're making their money all
right and they're killing Americans so
it's a win-win situation for China who's
holding them accountable all these
hearings all these judicial I'm watching
this [__] right now with Twitter none of
those guys are gonna get in trouble none
of them are going to go to jail they're
gonna investigate fauci fauci's
Untouchable he'll never mark my words
never none of them will ever see jail
ever period they're gonna go in front
Jim Jordan will yell at him Rand Paul
will yell at him then what it's going to
happen no I'm being real what happens
Pat there's a total lack of
accountability in DC nobody ever gets
one thousand percent that's it we didn't
start in this country with an
aristocracy but now we have one in
Washington DC it's called the permanent
bureaucracy it doesn't matter how how
much you suck at your job you get
promoted you are basically on fireable
exactly the worst that can happen to you
is that you get reassigned to a
different department you are pampered
you earn a lot of money you can you
barely have to go to work it's a nice
job if you can get it I wish I could get
in I have no desire to get it okay
that's not going to be yeah and Pat take
us out on maybe um
I have nothing to say take us out on a
more up the future looks brighter even
Elon Musk said it we're trying to have
babies in the last 100 years we've
overcome the Great Depression we've
overcome World War One Two a president
assassination an attempt president
assassination an assassination of MLK
assassination of RFK 911 we've overcome
a lot of things uh is what we've
overcome I think what is awesome about
Seasons like this is seeing leaders
rising up leaders don't wake up during
times of Peace unfortunately Lee leaders
typically are identified and step up
during times of War times of Crisis
times of uncertainty times of fear I
believe the man upstairs is looking down
right now saying okay this is the next
challenge that's being faced let's see
what kind of leaders are going to rise
up and your job and my job is to start
off with our family first
within your household beater leader
within the company that you're working
at choose to be a leader amongst your
peers choose to be a leader amongst your
community your city choose to be amongst
your church if you do go to anything
choose to be a leader if we choose to be
leaders the other I was having a
conversation with Dylan we're driving
the car now letting them play you watch
the video of Dana White where he says
this is the season of savages
and I had him watch it and he says if
you're a Savage
if you're remotely a Savage you're gonna
can kill everybody in this generation if
you're remotely a Savage him and
Cardinal and having a conversation it's
actually a very good one and a Cardone
says I don't care what people say in
every generation there's a Savage he
says yes and then I look at Dylan and
I'm saying hey what do you what do you
think your Savages his dad I'm a Savage
assistant you think you're a Savages I'm
a Savage as well I said you have to be
David blood you don't have a choice
you're a Savage okay and he says but
that you know goes back to the same
conversation yes but Dad you keep saying
to David lasts him as a special last
name you know you're just saying that
that's not true I said the only thing
that matters is for us to believe it 100
Nothing Else Matters it's our job to
lead our people I feel like that about
my background I feel like that about
America I feel like that about
valuetainment I feel like that about
capitalism I feel like that about
insurance I feel like that about
anything you represent you ought to have
that kind of respect
determination confidence in so if you to
lead
things are going to work out does it
mean we're going to go through someones
I think something weird is going on I
think some weird shit's gonna happen
uh but you know just like you know
history repeats itself leaders are going
to rise up that's what's going to happen
at the end of the day it's a season
we're having a conversation with a
couple guys in this in the Cigar Lounge
one guy says what topic should be off
limits you know what I told them I said
no topic should be off limits to discuss
today at a dinner or family setting it's
our approach that needs to improve I
agree you can talk any topic let's learn
our approach to make it a little bit
more comfortable for all of us have a
conversation together if you believe the
future looks bright order your future
looks bright hat today
[Music]